hi I'm Justine and I was born to create
I've always loved creating ever since I
was younger photography art making home
videos you name it what makes creating
even easier nowadays is technology and
that is one of the reasons that I love
it so much in my downtime I really enjoy
playing video games so I partnered with
Lenovo to showcase the world's first
laptop built for cloud gaming this is
the Lenovo IdeaPad gaming Chromebook
with 120hz QHD display this multi-zone
RGB gaming keyboard and no need for
gaming installs you will instantly have
access to thousands of games it is so
much fun and it's super impressive how
you can play processor intensive games
in the cloud using this device allows me
to not only game on the go but continue
to create and run my business from
anywhere I'd love to hear from you
though what were you born to do thank
you again to Lenovo for sponsoring this
video